you know I think we all know something
special happened yesterday on
Brotherhood 2.0 but I don't I don't
think we have to talk about it I don't
think we have to go into details about
how it felt or how wonderful it was it's
like the last night of camp you know you
experience it and you just know because
it's in here good morning Hank Howell
makes noise it's Tuesday January 30th
hold on one second I just I just have to
I just have to play my new Wii yes yes
it occurs to me now that playing the Wii
is one of those things that feels a lot
cooler than it looks
something from the comments commenter
anonymous wait isn't that say Frank's
thing doesn't he say so something from
the comments we got to think of
something else we got to have like a
voices from the comments Anonymous says
Hank you keep raising the bar I feel
kind of bad for John in his unending
bull position of following your postings
you feel kind of bad for John Jesus
Anonymous try being John huh what am I
gonna do today I got some in your pants
jokes anybody want to hear some in your
pants jokes but Hank I'd like to discuss
a serious issue which is the issue of
everyone poops Hank the question I have
for you and our viewership is this which
is funnier everyone poops in my pants or
everyone poops in your pants
Brotherhood 2.0 project once we decide
whether everyone poops in your pants or
everyone poops in my pants is funnier
I'm going to write an entire picture
book called one of those two titles
which I will then read on the air maybe
if we get lucky the Yeti will do some
drawings in other news I seem to have
accidentally CCD you on an email
stupid stupid this means that I have to
do a punishment Hank
be kind to me remember
we're brothers I'll see you tomorrow